i've never thought structure first
i've always thought material first and i
think you're the same with evicts and
and that's how we operate so much
material first jokes first character
first and then we just put them all on
the wall um and then honestly just the
game of what if you put this next to
this and usually the more unusual that
pairing is with those scenes all those
things you put in an episode the more
interesting it it comes with something
something happens when you put two
things that should be together and then
you start pulling a story out of that
knowing the end really really helps yeah
good to go far away from the end
emotionally as you possibly can that's
my instinct anyway and i think knowing
how you and we were doing our dry right
stuff theater stuff um early on a lot of
our experiments were how do you want to
make the audience feel like what is the
journey emotional journey you want them
to go on and that really helps me rather
than thinking like
starting off thinking like this would
work a story b story c story
it's at this point if you found a moment
a scene that you know works and it's
going to make them feel that you need to
hit them with it as a surprise so then
work away from that